after weeks and weeks of making strange
insensitive
and ignorant comments uh related to jews
and judaism radical republican
congresswoman marjorie taylor green
appears to have had a i don't really
want to call it a come to jesus moment
because
it relates to the holocaust now you
might remember that marjorie taylor
green equated having to wear a mask on
the floor of the house of
representatives
to how the jews were treated during the
holocaust and she said mandatory
vaccinations are like the holocaust
even there are even though there are no
mandatory vaccinations
then she doubled down on the analogy but
later denied ever having made it
but now marjorie taylor greene visited
the holocaust museum
in washington dc and then made a
statement that you know what she was
wrong
she apologizes the holocaust was really
very bad
and there's nothing comparable to it
presumably meaning mask wearing is not
like the holocaust and vaccinations are
not like the holocaust
check this out this is marjorie taylor
green fresh off of the realization that
the holocaust was really bad
always want to remind everyone i'm very
much a normal person
and i think it's important for me to
always be transparent and
honest and i just want to tell you all
i'm really really lucky i was blessed
with
i am blessed with amazing parents and my
dad
just passed away in april
but i will say he taught me some great
things
and one of the best lessons that my
father always taught me
was when you make a mistake you should
own it
and i have made a mistake and it's
really bothered me
for a couple of weeks now and so i
definitely want to own it
this afternoon i visited the holocaust
museum
the holocaust is
there's nothing comparable to it it's
it's
it happened and you know over six
million
jewish people were murdered more than
that there were
not just jewish people black people
christians all kinds of children
people that that the nazis didn't
believe were
good enough or perfect enough
and the horrors of the holocaust are
something that
some people don't even believe happen
and some people deny but there is
no comparison to the holocaust so
marjorie taylor green there not only
saying she was wrong for her holocaust
comparisons
even calling out holocaust deniers and
will watch a little bit more where she
specifically says
she said offensive things and she
apologizes for saying them
and there are words that i have said
remarks that i've made
that i know are offensive and for that i
want to apologize
and i am i am just fine
and very glad to be able to come out
here and do that because i believe it's
important
i believe that if we're going to leave
we need to be able to lead in a way
where if we've messed up it's very
important for us to say we're sorry
all right so listen she does sound
sincere in a way
but it's also kind of a weird word salad
with very little emotion
how if you really didn't know how bad
the holocaust was
how do you go through the holocaust
museum apparently unaware
of what you were in for learning about
it for the first time
and you come out of it with such a lack
of emotion now
whether the sincerity is coming from her
belief that the things she said
are horrible and offensive or the
sincerity is coming from her realizing
that i've got to clean this up because
this this looks really bad for me i
don't know
but she's doing something that lots of
these politicians never do which is
simply to say
i was wrong trump didn't say i was wrong
i apologize
once in four years so i give her credit
for that
but i don't really know that she didn't
mean it when she said it i think when
she said that stuff
about masks and vaccinations on the
holocaust uh
i think she did mean it and we're
getting into evaluating what's in her
mind and that's really tough
but how does a 47 year old woman get to
be 47 years old and not know how bad the
holocaust was and this is what gives me
the most pause
great she's zoning up she's saying she
was wrong she's apologizing that's
that's a great thing
but how does a 47 year old american
who as far as i know went to school not
realize
how bad the holocaust was and think up
until age 47
that wearing a mask at arby's is sort of
like the holocaust in any way and then
you learn you're wrong at age 47
if you're really that ignorant you have
no business being a member of congress
if you're not that ignorant and you're
lying to save yourself
you also have no business being a member
of congress don't
most american children know by age 10
how bad the holocaust was
and if by age 10 you only had an idea by
age
20 don't you really know how bad the
holocaust was
and even if at age 20 you skipped class
on that day
by age 30 don't you understand it
totally and completely how do you arrive
at age 47 with such little idea about it
that she thought masks were sort of like
the holocaust
until she visited the holocaust museum
come on guys something about this
stinks to high heaven let me know what
you think
i am curious to hear your thoughts what
if any of this is actually sincere
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely
free service at privacy.com
pacman i've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number
the privacy app and the browser plug-in
let you give each company
a randomized virtual credit card number
that you create
out of thin air it'll even autofill the
card number with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information so this allows you to
keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create up to 12 of these virtual credit
cards
a month you can set spending limits you
can freeze them
you can delete them anytime you want so
when you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over
if i use a virtual credit card number
you're keeping your identity private
by not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or
credit card info protected against data
breaches and identity theft
and it's free and like i said you'll get
five dollars to spend when you sign up
at
privacy.com slash pacman